do you know what a vpn is right we've
done this yeah okay we'll say that then
yes right which one's your favorite surf
shock
brilliant everyone knows what surf shark
is you've heard it hundreds of times on
hundreds of youtube videos it's an app
and browser extension which allows you
to put your laptop
anywhere in the world not physically
like netflix yeah
right his challenge right
try and tell me as much as you can
remember about surfshot from the
previous times that we've done it
and i will tell you if you're right or
wrong it's like netflix right
sorry sorry when you want to watch
netflix and other countries
you can use a vpn right and you can
literally switch your location
right so if you want to watch something
cool in france or america or wherever
right you can be
there right or if there's some protected
content that you want to watch from
al jazeera or whatever you want to watch
wow you want to watch that yeah
it does what does vpn stand for oh it's
tricky isn't it i had to google it
because i couldn't remember
virtual private network oh yeah that
sounds kind of nice to have doesn't it a
virtual private network does make it
feel
like you can go online and no one's
going to be snooping on you while you're
oh yeah because that's
because you guys call it you got
encryption that's it brilliant they
encrypt your data
and stay anonymous online you love being
anonymous online
in general really the one good thing
about wearing these bloody face masks is
no one asks for a picture anymore yeah
to be to be fair you're probably one of
the few people where people still go
no they don't they do the double take
but then they go i can't be sure i'm not
gonna go
yeah it could be eddie hall then you
should [__] run you have
passed the test there but it also goes
the other way so not only can you watch
netflix in other countries but if you're
in another country and you want to watch
uk netflix
you can also do that one of the things i
do remember yeah the surf shop is the
only
vpn where you can use one account on all
your things right okay so you don't have
to have like a different account for
every little hardware
so you tell me i could use it on this
but also this all of them
all within one price all of them that's
it it's all inclusive they've actually
changed they've changed the deal what
the deal's worth it's better
what four months four what four months
extra free so you're telling me that not
only do now i have 84
off i also get four months extra for
free
absolutely wow 30 day money back
guarantee as well i've just read that
yeah forgot about that right you
shouldn't don't forget that that's a
massive one yeah don't forget
it's probably all the boxing you're
doing punch one thing out another thing
goes back in
go click the link in the description
please use code geordi because it
reminds them that we were sending you
there so if shark sponsor in the episode
thanks a lot surf shark get on with true
news it's gonna be a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
true news [__]
a place where you get all your [__] up
[__] on the internet in one
easy to watch video you wonder why you
didn't get an xbox or a playstation
what's up he was showing them all the
[__] up [__] all the other people
fairies and ponies and unicorns
hold on a minute there's a pandemic
apparently that doesn't get you an xbox
or a playstation for free so
you did not get an xbox one shove it up
your ass microsoft wanted one
no we'll have a playstation right yeah
we'll buy our own thanks should we start
with the serious stuff or the [__] up
[__]
uh serious stuff how would you describe
jeffrey start as someone who just landed
on earth hard not to be offensive here
isn't it
yeah post up willy wonka that's pretty
good that's actually pretty good
world of pure imagination with
chocolates
yeah for makeup that would be incredible
wouldn't it why do you think all the
young plumpers have orange faces because
they're all trying to get the kim
kardashian look there you go well
they've got the little
fat white you're walking around the fact
you're going [__] oh
[__] that one [__] that one yeah
have you seen the the blood money reveal
but blood money
is nothing blood or money related it
sounds more like a g
unit record
[Music]
that looks like some sort of illuminati
government things
it's not to be fair if the illuminati
you did want to induct someone jeff
would be a good place to start
you walk in the illuminati and they'll
go could you do us a favor
you know the makeup that you're getting
put on your faces could we use it to
give them cancer
[Music]
this is what cruella de vil's sex dreams
are like
i'm pretty sure that's the guy who
robbed him last time yeah yeah i brought
your stuff back
this year it's been [__] rough and i
think that sometimes maybe we make it
look
easy on social media jeffrey let's just
be clear no one thinks that looking like
that
is easy i really yeah that looks like a
chore no one envies you
five hours of getting ready before i
could even look look outside the house
i like the fact that the one thing he
does to try and remain like even
semi-casual wears a dressing gown on
every video right that's the only bit of
him that looks low me
yeah exactly yeah but i just want to
share
just us i'm done with people who know
they have a big audience and go
just us we're not your friends so i
tried a bunch of new things
a lot of it did not work and it rubbed
you guys the wrong way
and the sales must have been very good
yeah yeah you know just us
if we could just nobody on youtube gives
a [__] about what their fans really
think as long as the money's still
coming in jeffrey
i don't know if you know this right
there's a global pandemic
and people are losing their jobs left
right and center
it's nothing to do with your shitty
palette it's to do with the fact that we
can't afford to pay
for dust in a packet and that's what
makeup is
ultimately dust in a packet but it's
colorful yeah a colorful dust
in the pocket let's be honest of all the
dusts and packets yours is the last one
i would choose right that's a very good
point
now going from one fake person to
another completely real person who lives
in the real world and the birthday
present that kim kardashian got
good old kanye bought her a birthday
present he reincarnated her dad
for the day that's nice isn't it yeah
you love it don't you
just love it when you go i'm gonna
resurrect your dad
we're basically watching a ghost that
has been programmed to speak
by kanye to his wife look at you
you're 40 and all grown up you look
beautiful just like when you were a
little girl
not just like when you were a little
girl i feel like some of your features
may have been slightly adjusted since
that age
what happened to your breasts kim and
your your ass
yeah and your face and your nose and
your eyes and the hair
and your waist yeah and your legs you've
lost more fat than my corpse
sometimes i drop hints that i'm around
like when you hear someone make a big
pifi
or when you make a big pifi his face is
really not animated properly here it
just really do you know
silence to the lambs where dr lecter
wears the face of his victim
yes a bit more like that right i think
that's exactly that's what's actually
happened here
is kanye in that no i can say this
surprise you didn't go
mental at this what are you doing making
my father's corpse talk to me
he's not the corpse brian it's like when
tupac came back and did the coachella
thing yeah it's one thing doing hit them
up it's another thing going i watch all
of you every day and sometimes you'll
hear me
i think what he's saying in this here is
when you do a fart maybe it's a spirit
escaping her butthole i mean if you want
to live somewhere in eternity
why not kim kardashian's [__] i am
so proud of the woman that you've become
kimberly and all that you've
accomplished
and the way you sucked on ray jay's dick
really made me yeah
the moment when you took the kardashian
name to a new height the way you backed
that ass up wow there you go
baby right there when you posed
completely naked covered in silver paint
your father had a semi the way that
you're connecting with your roots and
supporting armenia means so much to me
you are a proud armenian and i am a
proud armenian father in the same way as
my father often looks at me and goes
you're a proud englishman
and i am a proud english father the most
beautiful thing that i have witnessed
is watching you grow your family
literally watching you and kanye
shrugged like animals yeah tremendous he
is an absolute horse
just to be clear i really think you
should suck him off a lot more i know
kanye loves reverse cowgirl
that's one thing he's like and he hasn't
told me to say this yeah exactly but
definitely do doggy sail more just to be
clear because looking at your stupid
dumb face makes him
really upset you married the most
most most most most genius man
in the whole world even the actor was
like rolling his eyes there going like
[__] crap is this what it's called
you know you studied are you an actor
and then
next thing you know you're uh you're
doing this for canyon connie's
imagine you write your own script for
your wife's dead father to deliver back
to her and you call yourself the most
most most
most most most most most genius person
in the whole wide world
kanye's sitting in the audience that's a
good one got your dad's approval see
yeah say you always wondered yeah now we
have the answer
stop worrying about dad wouldn't like me
yeah clearly
he loves me yeah exactly yeah you are
the most
most most most amazing mother to your
four
beautiful children the scriptwriter just
run out of adjectives
it's like what we've got we gotta rush
this through what's another word for
most i [__] will just add three more
in it'll do
she'll just be happy to see her dead dad
it won't even matter we could just have
him stand there breathing it'd be fine
yeah she'd literally go oh my god does
he say anything
very little i would love it if you know
at the end of this he just opened his
mouth and bats flew out
i'm in [__] hell the devil's got me
he said i did it for defending oh gee i
shouldn't have done it
at the end of the video is these flames
just taking him back to hell he's just
going
see you later kim and kanye just goes ah
he's probably looking up at us now
looking up at us yeah he just goes down
below what did you make of this
first of all she's parking in a no
parking zone that's what i was outraged
by
it amused me because a couple of people
uh sent me this saying um seems up your
street brian right
why shape right um what is what's that
street well i guess curvy
credit to billy eilish has just strived
to take herself seriously as an artist
she sort of covered herself she's not
wanting to be a sex symbol and all of
that sort of stuff she's not in the
conventional way she's covered up for
ages because she wants you to listen to
the music and not
you know treat her in the way that um
remember when like christine aguilera
all of a sudden just came out and
changed her image and she was rocking
around [__] around her way on in the
middle of the music video
yeah and she's not trying to be
sexualized trying to be taken seriously
more as an artist
so i i felt a bit for her that they'd
sort of did gotta
sort of speak and they tried to shame
her a little bit for looking like this
some twitter accounts did right i mean
everyone gets shamed on twitter really
it doesn't mean that she's being brave
by dressing this way either right
she's been called going to the shops you
know i mean it's not a big deal but it
becomes a big deal because of who she is
but it shouldn't really be a big deal a
woman has boobs
isn't the news people need to just calm
the [__] down like this she's not being
really brave yeah
and if people have slated out and
they're an [__]
obviously because not every female music
artist is going to be
like a tiny little ariana grande looking
[__] absolutely
and news flash [__] learn to love
someone and let other people be
themselves you [__] i don't turn
around to brian and go
that's getting a bit saggy just touched
my ass
cardi b accidentally posted uh i think
an instagram story or something of her
nipples out people made a
few comments about them because uh
they're sort of bigger than what a lot
of women have
she had back in the day so her nipples
were quite sort of
small yeah now she's had a baby the
nipples have gone
bigger the areola right it's gone bigger
you know i don't know
it's it's caused a bit of a stir hasn't
it she looked fantastic in the whap
video yeah
she's growing on me because she's so
sassy i'm kind of like you know the time
she says things i'm like and you sound a
bit silly there but she'd be interesting
to date i think she'd make a good
interview some of the lyrics she says
i'm like
you've got an extensive it's an
extensive knowledge
in making men sound good right okay so
yeah yeah when you listen to that i'm
like
back that big mac trap and you're like
oh you know about trucks
i genuinely it does make me think we can
finish
[__] and then you let me read
autotrader
genuinely she just you can tell she's
got a great imagination
this is a sad story actually a policeman
died when raiding
a [__] fight but not the reason you
think i know you want to laugh here
it's it's just the the strangeness of
the story i'm not laughing at anyone
else's
misfortune no it's just very odd that
you look at two [__] going at it and
then somehow they killed a copper
right okay yeah i think i've seen that
on pornhub a police officer is was
killed during a raid of an illegal
cockfighting event in the philippines
when a rooster with a blade and imagine
what they do is they have the blades
fitted on the like the claws of the
rooster the rooster didn't go
hold up the pigs are here what are you
doing and the policeman's going
whoa he's got a blade back off [__]
lieutenant
christian bollock god you've got to see
how how weird is it that [__] fighting
and bob he'd pick the rooster up while
collecting evidence
when he was sliced by a steel razor
blade attached to the bird's leg and he
just bled out
colonel arnel a pud said it was a piece
of bad luck that i cannot explain
this is my first time in 25 years as a
policeman that a man was lost to
fighting a [__] spur imagine colonel
arnold a pud turning up to the cop's
wife's house
uh hello officer uh can i help you uh
you have somebody have some bad news
not christian he was the most most most
most genius man it turns out um not that
genius because um
he's the most most most most most dead
man now unfortunately
um he died was it a robbery or something
what drug deal gone bad
what was it i knew this day would come i
told him yeah don't be getting involved
with those criminals well you should
have told him don't be getting involved
with those chickens
leave the [__] alone leave the house
here it's not that again
yeah after a courting with them fellas i
thought yeah
no no no no glenda no no not that no no
no a chicken sliced in with a blade oh
sorry i thought you said a chicken's
license
is this some sort of joke no no he
always loved kfc exactly yeah no
well if anything you know he ate his
fair share in life some would say poetic
justice yeah exactly really yeah so
are you seeing yeah that my husband was
killed by a chicken
he has revenge for all of the kfc he ate
during his life
don't be putting words in my mouth i
would not say that i'm just saying
yeah it's funny how the world works yeah
i love the idea that in in collecting it
he goes over to chicken he goes right
spread them and the chicken goes bruh
i've not got anything police chief was
known as the colonel
yeah how did he die well i can't tell
you it's my own special blend
to be fair it was a hard death and she
went i will admit this is a zinger
to be fair a man has died here we're
awfully sorry for the loss
all right all righty now from the
caption
i can tell you that some people may find
this shocking
check this out you ready no over here
right
[Music]
she's there she's there she's there
she's okay she's there can i show you
the other angle just to be sure
look there she's there i mean i'm not
sure if that was a paddle or what let's
see the other angle
oh no that looks like a clean sweep bro
that looks like a
clean sweep that is
goodbye good night they know showing off
a bit and i think that's because
you couldn't really see she stood up
inside the woods inside the whale's
mouth
what the [__] was through your head
there i love the fact that she's still
holding on to the punch yeah well to be
fair
that would be a good way to fight your
way out i love the fact that our
husband's watching one oh thank
[__] for that yeah he went i'll sip you
the 20 questions later watch this is my
day mike's a friend of the show
obviously we've had him on the podcast
multiple times now chatted to him
multiple times off the podcast he seems
like a great guy he was great and
he had this relationship with lana
rhodes famous porn star
right we all watched it happen logan
presented him with lana it was perfect
they hid it off suddenly and i expected
that yeah everyone was a bit single a
bit like oh well this will last two or
three
videos and suddenly they were actually
in a long-term relationship it's just
impossible
to maintain a relationship i feel under
that much like
pressure and being on camera together
constantly
most relationships just do not survive
the public eye
agree and i'm not saying that that's why
they've ended let's see what he says
yeah thanks bro i appreciate you have
fun
don't cry i'll try not to
i'll try not to he's an emotional guy
yeah he's lovely
yeah what would you do on the field
you've gone let's clock in and we'll be
where we're going not the mic not now so
i guess for people who have been
watching the channel over the past year
the big question is why
why are you guys breaking up you seem so
happy on camera
there was no one specific reason it
wasn't a loyalty thing
the best thing about amra is that she is
so fiercely loyal i never once had to
worry about her cheating
talking to any other guys i felt
watching them that was the case like
when he released his book and she
probably promoted it more than he did
i was like you're a [__] legend right
yeah like she must have boosted her
sales
50 if not 100 yeah she clearly
loved him yeah that and and i think he
loved her as well so that was never
in question no no and so over the past
couple months
she was trying to
facilitate the vision that she saw for
the relationship which was getting a
house and me moving in with her
and rightfully so all those things made
complete sense to her facilitate is a
really nice way of
saying she was sort of pushing her
agenda right i
might be out of order here but just as a
man you know when the woman's going
let's move forward
let's let's do that more seriously next
more seriously yeah
yeah and as a guy when that's happening
and you're not ready to run
you're just happy jogging for a bit it
becomes difficult then well two
different cases
well what you what you find is the more
the other person's going
more serious more serious the more you
go oh no not yet not yet no okay
and then the more that they feel you
putting the brakes on the more they push
harder it inevitably will get to a point
where it goes
what do you want what do you want and
then you both sit and go i guess this
isn't gonna work then does it okay yeah
you know what i mean yeah and you get to
a bit of a
party at a crossroads right yeah it's
like that bit in um fast and furious
where they've been
a long long day without you my friend
yeah and i'll tell you and then
i felt for a long time um
that there was just something missing in
the relationship there's also a bunch of
things that i'm not even gonna get into
today that were just
signs that we wanted two vastly
different things in life and that we
weren't
um that we weren't cut out to be
together and that we weren't cut out to
to go the distance i feel like sometimes
when you first meet someone as well
it's really exciting you know and
probably having great sex i mean let's
be honest we all know they were having
great sex
and then after a while though it needs
to stand on its own two legs and
actually
you find out who that person is and this
is when you start feeling like are we
right
is this compatible yeah do we are we
actually into all the same things or are
we just telling ourselves we are because
we like each other right
you know what i mean it's a shame yeah
because they look great together and
they
they were like youtube royalty you know
in a way very quickly as well
and they were doing all these big
numbers on his channel as well
huge numbers but they were also
charismatic they were fun to watch
right yeah some couples they could send
a glass eye asleep she should take them
or leave them
yeah i mean boring but these two box
offices right they loved it yeah
so which one both well oh who's all this
from
manscript yes thank you very much
manscaped i have been using this as well
so
they've sent us fresh ones but i've been
using the other ones now that barbers
are closed this is pretty ideal for me
he does everything i'm taking this
does everything oh they've sent two each
yeah that's one for me one for you
oh that's lovely but normally i do your
back with yours anyway so that's a left
side about that about actually i don't
have a hairy back they've seen that they
watch the rebuild
yeah it's also it's quite light hair
back here it's sort of yeah it sort of
thickens towards the ass
we've been doing this this is too much
fun thanks to manscape 2 are sponsoring
today's episode
of true news appreciate you guys um
they've got a really great offer on 20
off when you go to manscape.com slash
true they've got all sorts man they've
oh they've got the right tools for the
job
wipes with active ph control i'm not
even joking
you have a real hard time controlling
the ph of your balls you're seeing
things as if you know that it's not true
actually
now with manscaped i'll never have to
worry about that right exactly
yeah yeah now we've got the weed waka as
well we don't have to worry about
the nostrils the ears when you're a real
man you get hair in all sorts of places
and women
women don't want that people think that
this all happens by accident it's nice
i'm lined up i'm ready for action any
day anytime anywhere
okay that's because of manscape 20 off
manscape.com
true you know it again now it's time to
talk politics so switch off now if you
don't like
politics or stick around if you like
comedy donald trump
won the election if you count all the
votes he wants you to count
good evening i'd like to provide the
american people with an update on our
efforts
by the way this is the most serious i've
ever seen donald trump it serious now
impacts him well this is the first time
i've seen him read from a script for a
startup that's when you know he's like i
gotta get this right now you should have
tried getting it right
before the election right okay yeah yeah
yeah
to protect the integrity of our very
important 2020 elections
i'm not actually as anti-trump as some
people are i find him
quite funny actually it's not reason to
have him as a president is it definitely
not
if there's one thing i don't think
donald trump and
the next word is never integrity right
you know what i mean
chaos right chaos suspicion yeah you
don't look at the man and go there goes
a man with integrity
yeah yeah definitely not if you count
the legal votes
i easily win if you count the illegal
votes they can try to
steal the election from us if you count
the votes that came in late we're
looking at them very strongly but a lot
of votes came in late so for quite some
time now we've all seen donald trump has
been very carefree about the virus
saying we need to get back to normal as
soon as possible naturally the people
who are staying at home terrified of the
virus and don't want to go out and cute
of all
probably not gonna be voting for trump
the logical thing to expect
is that the mailing bullets are gonna be
in favor of
biden him trying to cast doubt over
magically all these mailing ballots are
forbidden
i mean it just makes sense yeah a man
who by the way told his support base to
use mail-in ballots joe biden
whether you agree with him or not that's
what he told them to do yeah and
statistically the male imbalance for
whatever reason
are usually democrats anyway but it's
just logical this
isn't there is no conspiracy for once on
this channel we're not talking about
conspiracy theory
we're actually just talking about a dumb
[__] who can't take losing
of all the presidents who've lost he is
taking it the worst
in the history of what makes you say
that well he's just not accepted it
right okay so
i'd say he's taking it the worst he's
that boyfriend that in a few years time
you'll look back and go
thank god i left him but at the time
when you're in it you're going this is
great and all your friends are going
definitely get away from that one this
one is [__] mental
i've already decisively won many
critical states including massive
victories in florida
iowa indiana ohio state
doesn't matter i won some states
decisively yes yes you did
you didn't win enough pal yeah you know
what i mean that's what happens in
elections in football if you score
three that's great if the other teams
score four you lost you lose
yeah trump then tweeted he was going to
hold a press conference at the four
seasons philadelphia the four seasons
philadelphia tweeted back we don't have
a booking
for trump at the four seasons
philadelphia donald trump then deleted
this tweet
and found out that he booked the four
seasons garden center
in philadelphia a news conference had
been called
why here we don't know but with the
podium in place
out walk the president's lawyer rudy
giuliani
wow what a beautiful day thank you a man
who's draining the money out of the
president before ultimately we realize
he no longer has the money that he said
and as he spoke the news came in that
joe biden had been declared the victor
who was it called by
all the oh my goodness all the networks
wow all the networks
we have to forget about the law i mean
that is quite a big number yeah that's
normally something you go for though
isn't it
this is so childish at this point he's
like wow it's like no
yes wow yes yes wow you should be seeing
wow that is a lot yeah
politics is so divisive isn't it in
america i think especially but i think
it's
especially divisive when you have what's
the phrase [__] at the very top
yeah fair enough but like it's like when
you see stuff like this right so you've
got an old guy there with the make
america great again catboy
face red screaming at the other side
right this guy saying i love you i mean
he bodied up the sky by the way right
yeah
shredded i wonder if you look you just
had a pint with a guy or a coffee or
whatever and just sat and talked to each
other yeah i wonder if there'd be any
comment
but they just saw like my team against
your team right and you get
a tribal mentalities here's what happens
you just can't think
the whole political system is set up to
prey on that
they want to divide us they want to keep
us going our side's right your side's
wrong
right you're a republican all [__]
realize what an
absolute pile of [__] politics is
presidential spiritual advisor paula
white currently
leading an impassioned that's one way to
describe it prayer service
in an effort to secure trump's
re-election
did it work i'll let you be there yeah
let's see i hear a sound of abundance of
rain
i hear a sound of victory i hear a sound
of shouting and singing i hear
a sound of victory what was she hearing
because it wasn't victory so she is
hearing something
we don't know
you go from one priest to another priest
do you know this guy
he runs a bowl pretty unscrupulous
[__] he's basically made a lot
of money out of his uh
through his life are you saying he's an
evil man uh yeah i'm saying this guy's
an absolute and his face
tells that kind of story laughter is
a deterrent to pain they've they have
proven it is that
a priest quoting science yeah well as a
priest quoting i'd say spooky science as
he basically says you can laugh off pain
and like i said a merry heart does good
like a medicine so
the joy of the lord is our strength the
joy of the lord is our strength
lawrence mckenna and here's the thing if
you are actually religious i'd be pissed
off that someone was using
your stuff your good material on this
this is the best stuff
yeah this is the best stuff all right
well ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
[Music]
this associated prince said that joe
biden is president
[Music]
i love this guy love this guy i hate to
admit this but you'd be fascinated know
what the [__] this man is into sexually
wouldn't you oh absolutely yeah like he
just lays there and goes
[Laughter]
you know it'll be absolutely funny as
[__] as if he keeled over and
died
ken let's get a laugh out of ken ken
is that a death rattle do we have a
doctor in the house yeah and the
doctor's just about
oh god you kill me mercy oh he's
defended his lavish lifestyle oh no this
is the one
this is the one right okay so this is
why kenneth copeland was seen as a bad
guy basically kenneth copeland
basically said the more money you give
the closer you get to god
makes sense no that's how i am with my
my fans
the more money you give me the closer we
are yeah
exactly so donate how are you sir we'd
just like to ask you
about why you don't want to fly
commercial man's riding around in a
[__]
escalator it pretty is it's nice this
by is beautiful yeah huge car why have
you said that you won't fly commercial
you said that it's like getting into a
tube with a bunch of demons
i feel the same way it'd be fair i would
only fly first class if i could yeah so
you will preach
on him he's doing the lord's work trying
to do the lord's work while he's bumping
elbows with peasants yeah he can't do it
how the [__] am i going to pray if i
can't get a bit of that elbow room here
bring the champagne out now i want to
see how this guy justifies this i love
it i love inside edition
you got to get this now hey you
listening to me my my wife thinks inside
edition is
oh yeah now
thank you lord help me just let me let
me pray i need a moment um
i think i'm going to pray sorry i'll
just put you on hold i'm talking to god
right now
what you've just asked me a really
difficult question
god comes first so yeah you gotta i'll
be right with you
uh no god said i've got to go a lot of
people think it's unbecoming for a
preacher
to live a life of luxury and to fly
around in private jets
what's your response to that very simple
it takes a lot of money to do what we do
he's the rick ric
flair of priests
we have brought over a hundred let's see
this the latest figures just came out uh
122 million people to the lord jesus
christ
if that's the case and he's had 122
million people and they're all donators
what has he baptized them himself no
tonight he has the
most evil reptilian eyes i've ever seen
in my life if you literally walk up and
those eyes were looking at you you think
that is the devil right there yeah
because it is you know when
you see the movies where like the
religious guy gets what's coming to him
because he isn't actually doing the
lord's work and he's you know taking all
the gold
he's that guy he's the real person and
then you get a real priest who's like
you know living on [__] soup and
bread whatever just doing the good stuff
and this guy looks like a pimp he's
dressed like conor mcgregor in like 50
years
he is yeah without the airplane that we
have that i bought from tyler
perry and i didn't pay anywhere tyler's
one of the greatest guys
he made it's he made that airplane so
cheap for me i couldn't help but buy it
the next time i'll go wild on money los
you're just gonna take it i couldn't
help they made it
i'll tell you now son that lamborghini
was so
cheap i couldn't help but buy it okay
all right but i want to get to the
demons because people are very concerned
about that comment give me your chance
your inside edition
i love your eyes i do declare those eyes
have got some life in them
like the eyes of your children i'd
imagine that we know exactly where they
live
it you know the good old cold yeah but
luckily not worry about it
there's a cure but i'm not sure about
that there's a 90
cure yeah the people that we need to
trust over this pfizer of course
the maker of viagra if you don't know
you've got to think with that on a
business level
genius right who needs viagra all people
who's dying all people brilliant what do
we need to do
save the old people because we need them
to keep buying the viagra yeah we give
them
the protection for the virus and then we
give them another direction give them
the erection
protection erection then protect again
you're gonna need a condom well probably
not really at 60. did you think there
was anything in the timing of it a lot
of people suggested that the
deliberately not announced the cure
until after biden had one as if
or now it's biden title yeah i mean not
only that but they didn't want someone
else to take all the [__] credit and
go
i said from the start if we inject a
light into people's bodies trump has
actually said they've held off giving
him a win so basically the main campaign
against trump was you've not done enough
it's covered it's your fault people have
died it's your fault yeah having said
that though if the people have already
died i'm just gonna be absolutely clear
the vaccine doesn't bring them back my
love those people are dead and gone
i love the idea of this you could bring
them back kanye west right
[Music]
is it just me or do people not trust the
government with this would you take a
vaccine
it's pretty much the same response
everyone else has got isn't it it's not
that i don't want to help
and do my bit it's that i'm skeptical of
a lot of big institutions right now
and i want to see what happens let's
let's be honest people who are under a
certain age have got a very similar
attitude of this has been rushed
in the past certain things were rushed
through that led to
side effects that we didn't know existed
because the trials hadn't been long
enough
i'm thinking of things like i know it's
a wild example but the
thalidomide right you know those of you
out there might not remember there was a
drug given to pregnant women
to help combat morning sickness it had
negative effects on the babies right
and they came out with disabilities etc
so
ultimately if people feel like they're
in desperate need of it and they are in
the at-risk range
and they want to get this to then feel
confident enough
to go outside to see their families and
do all those things fair enough
personally i wouldn't get it because i
don't feel like i need it uh
same with the flu vaccine don't get it
for the same reason
it's not because i'm a denier of covid
or i'm anti-vaxx i'm not feel like it
should be there for people who need it
the point i'm making here you should
have control over your
own body and what i don't like the sound
of is when i hear reports of
it will be enforced or you will have to
do no government
in the history of mankind should ever
have the right to tell you you
have to put something in your body or
consequences that shouldn't happen so
you should have their own choice i
should have my choice
we should all have our own [__]
choice that's all i'm saying and then
helpfully in the middle of obviously uh
what most people are calling the second
wave or lockdown two as you wanna uh
term it uh rishi tsunak came back
apparently he's how to help out might
happen again
despite the fact that last time we found
out it may have actually worked on
spreading the virus he's in denial about
that
have you ever seen him answer the
question about that i don't find rishi
soon at that convincing though well
because he's a bullshitter
right the fact that we had to shut down
every [__]
restaurant and pull and this guy was a
big proponent of eat out the help out
and
spunk 500 million into it by the way
should we watch the interview where he
is it's put to him do you accept that
eat out to help out might have
contributed to the spread
of corvid 19. i'm not sure that's
exactly what the prime minister said he
said in general
as far as hospitality is a source of
transmission
that's why we should make sure we focus
our attention on it
how he tried to skirt around that was
amazing almost
yeah it's hospitality it's not eat out
to help out but you were encouraging
hospitality
yeah encouraging people to use the
hospitality i believe in what was
possible yeah because of course the
concept of eating out going to a
restaurant and being served at a table
to what help out which obviously would
have helped the businesses where you're
eating
apparently would have gone on to spread
the virus like exactly yeah can you
believe that he's the nines
uh no i can't believe that where yeah
what's happening here
is is pretty much in sync with what's
happening around the world in second
waves whether it's france
or spain where very specifically our
scientists said we were following
exactly the same curve
so actually there seems to be more
feature just of the virus and the season
than anything specific
nothing to do with no so why you shut
the pubs in restaurants
yeah it's just seasonal get a bit of
season on me food plot yeah exactly
yeah when i'm out in a nice fancy
restaurant like the [__] cat that i have
awkward though isn't it rishi because
your two facts don't go
they don't doesn't work does they do
that don't they
yeah it's nothing to do with eating out
oh you closed the pubs and restaurants
[__] well that is i was like than
that that is a tricky one
i think one thing we know is and
actually i speak to our scientists
almost every day
my question for rishi would what are you
talking to the scientist about
talk about the football he sort of goes
over and goes uh good morning
scientists and they go morning rishi
we're trying to get on with the work
see the football did you the good old
manchester reds yeah yeah yeah can we
get them with these texts
like the fact that boris barges then he
goes how are the uh the numbers looking
for the data what's the ruggers been
saying this weekend huh bloody good time
we're all having a receipt
yeah yeah
so this video clip was with the caption
nine months of separation a qualified
nurse looking to take her mother home
and care for her during the lockdown as
being arrested
in the meantime her 97 year old mother's
health continues to decline
my nan my 97 year old nan here who we
have taken from the care home because
we haven't seen her for nine months is
now being taken back by force
to her care home my mother has been
arrested
my mother is in the back of a car here
she is a nurse
she is a fully qualified nurse who is
wishing to care for her own mother
and here we have an incredible use of
police time
to take my 97 year old grandmother back
into a care home
where she is deteriorating where we
haven't been able to see her
for nine months this is really mental
now like this is
this is where we need to actually
realize like people's human rights are
actually being affected in the name of
kovard though like police are now just
going around going it's covered
we can do what we want this is insane
that's a wrong application of the law
though isn't it that is the wrong
application no
this this is what they believe to be
right because of the way
the government are structuring this
dollar big order kovid
do anything we want now covered you
can't do you've got no rights you you
just
that's it yeah in the name of kovid
you're not allowed to say your nan
that's it i feel like over the course of
this year as a group of people we're
being trained
to accept the new normal you've all
heard that saying the new normal
this ain't normal like we should not
take people just thinking they can do
whatever they want you in the name of
kovid it's [__] insane
this man's definitely in touch with a
few of the people at the very top of
like multiple covert private contracts
because 4 billion
we just can't tell you where we've spent
that do you know why because it went to
private contracts
and we don't really want people to know
where we've spent this money because if
the people find out where we spent the
money they might be a little bit annoyed
so the government have failed to publish
any information about any four billion
pounds worth of covered related
contracts awarded to private companies
and what appears to be a continuous
breach of uk law
that's all you need to know these people
are just spending money and then when we
say where did that money go they go
come on that's what i'm saying what is
dangerous about this
it reminds me of 9 11. after 9 11
so many things were brought into place
and whenever you questioned 9 11
it became the word that if you didn't
want to be challenged on why you were
changing the law
and human rights they sat near that you
just had to say 9 11. and corvid is now
becoming the exact same thing where if a
copper is in your face the idea
covered call it i can do i can i can
take your 90 year old grandmother off
you
kovid i can take this 4 billion and give
it to private companies
and if i get a kickback well so be it
covid
in years to come when people far smarter
than me investigate this
we are going to see a whole load of [__]
come out i've got no doubt about it
unfortunately
all we can do right now is smell how
fishy this is and
see the signs that people aren't acting
the way they should do in the best
interest of the
the people that they're governing that's
a bit of a donor to end on sorry
no no i think it's good news ultimately
we know that 4 billion was spent on
something
and 4 billion went back into the economy
so good news folks hope you enjoyed
the video don't forget to hit the like
button obviously hit the subscribe
button as well if you want should we put
that
put a graphic on the subscribe subscribe
um let's start oh for 85 percent of you
who are watching the video
aren't subscribed to me right now did
you watch that video as well
what thanks everyone cheers
thanks